this is Haiti's largest hospital and it
has been almost abandoned for five
months but even though no doctors are on
site some patients remain here because
they have nowhere else to go
Gina Cherry was shot by gang members in
December he used to be a mobile phone
salesman but he has not been able to go
back to work
I went to a private hospital and I spent
everything I had and then had to come
here I can't afford the medicines and
here there is nothing there are no
doctors to care for us
doctors at this hospital has been on
strike for months they say their
salaries the work environment and the
violence in the area make it almost
impossible to do their jobs
one of the most violent neighborhoods in
Porto Prince is not far from here since
the assassination of President
johannelmo is two years ago Haiti has
been caught in the middle of a political
and social crisis that has gangs
controlling the streets the interim
prime minister seems unable to restore
order
Evelyn Fremont says the government has
forgotten this Hospital which plays a
crucial role in the city's Health Care
System
the Haitian government doesn't care
about this place because they have
private hospitals to make money those
who can't afford a private Clinic have
nowhere else to go sometimes they die in
their homes there is no water or
electricity when we visited the patients
asked us for food this is the largest
hospital in Haiti and it has been rarely
working for the past five months the
Pediatrics eunuch has just started to
work once again very very slowly but
when we arrived here we saw all these
children that you can see here
that have been abandoned
is 12 years old
Kaku is 10.
and this baby is six months old
has been taking care of them
we stay here day and night so these
children aren't left alone we should
have gone because of the strike but we
can't leave them we feed them with
whatever we can find people in Haiti are
struggling with gang violence for
shortages and a non-functioning
government that has called on the
International Community for help for now
it seems the call remains unheard
there is